alright looks like people are still
trickling it but Michael go ahead and
get started my name is Brad Jaynes I've
been with them for about 6 years I work
in the education software technology so
it's my talk random problem generation
for the wolfram problem generator but I
get me can talk more I can tell you it's
so what I'm gonna talk about kind of the
basic idea let me make that a bit bigger
better ok so the basic idea of problem
generator is kind of what some other
people are doing our answer what we're
working on and what we'll be doing in
the future
and hopefully we'll have some Q&A time
at the end so the basic idea why make a
problem generator what is the problem
there it's a tool that generates random
problems hopefully they're random
they're usually math although there's
some science physics and things like
that happening out there it should have
some form of input or interactivity and
it should check at the users answer is
correct there you go to me there's kind
of two markets for such a tool
the first one is educators so more and
more educators are moving to online
assignments if you are under age 30
you've probably used search certain
things textbooks home worksheets these
things are all finite and they're
numbers of problems automatic grading is
a huge plus and then can prevent
cheating you know people are could be
looking off the other you know off of
their neighbors sheet if they if they
have different problems so it's just a
silly little gift I found
all right and then towards students many
subjects especially math benefit from
repetition of problems problem
generators can have as many problems as
you need decreases the need to carry
around textbooks and you get immediate
feedback on whether you're right or
wrong so the traditional thing of
turning in your quiz and waiting a week
and forgetting what you did before you
get any feedback off that kind of goes
away with something like this I'm not
going to get too into some issues that
that we've tried to target with ours but
so some of these problems generators
there might not be truly random answer
checking is a huge issue this example
here it shows enter your response is a
real number rounded to two decimal
places their answer fifteen point eight
three the expected answer was fifteen
point eight two six which is not to two
decimal places so there's things like
that all over the place plus the the
pedicle pedagogical ideas of like what
is a correct rounding rule what's the
most simplified form of an expression
things like that and then if you're not
using like a free response type input
field then should you use true or false
should you use multiple choice these
have their own issues and then there's a
the idea of getting feedback on your
answer this particular one it says the
correct answer does not depend on the
variable and there's no variable end in
their answer that they put in here
there's like a Ln like natural log but
who knows what happened there overall
students tend to not like these systems
very much okay so our problem generated
the the things that we've tried to fix
it's true random problem generation we
use random we use various statistics
functions that are in Mathematica for
all of our problems I answer checking we
we use the parser of from Wolfram Alpha
to parse the users input and
we have kind of functions on top of that
to to kind of tailor the users input
towards the particular problem type so
whether whether it's a vector we're
looking specifically for various ways
you could even put a vector and I'll
show some of that off in a minute
we provide feedback to users so we
immediately check their answer we have
the input interpretation where we kind
of show what we think that you typed in
we have hints that we give up on a wrong
answer and finally we make use of
Wolfram Alpha step-by-step solutions and
we also track your history per session
so you can kind of go back and look at
your the problems that you've already
done we also provide multiple choice as
an option for all of our problems in the
form of like problem sheets so like a
quiz and we we put a lot of effort into
making the the wrong answers for
multiple choice which we label as
distractors we put a lot of effort into
making those smart so those are also
randomly generated but kind of
programmatically generated and kind of
in in summary like people seem to like
this the most common type of feedback we
get is people asking for new content so
it seems like people just want more so
I'm gonna show off a few things so
here's the homepage you can kind of
search by topic and kind of dive down
into individual topics sometimes down to
the method like if you look at calculus
like if you just want to practice power
rule derivatives like you can do that we
also have summary sections for like you
know pick a random problem from one of
these above so if you want to you know
study for your derivatives test or
whatever you can also browse by about
common core standards these are the the
US common core so you kind of look at
what its kind of hard to read but you
kind of check out that the individual
standards and you know for this third
grade one you can see like we have some
integer
take stuff so for a particular problem
like I said with the power of Wolfram
Alpha sparser you can type in the answer
however you want and I'm gonna do some
live math for you guys so don't judge
and I think that's right cool
so there I didn't use parentheses or
anything you can use curly brackets
friends whatever and if you don't know
how to type something and we have these
nice palettes that you can kind of check
this out and you know that's eight so if
I get something wrong it'll it'll pop up
a message so here's that enter in put
interpretation where it shows what you
what we think that you typed in so for
twelve it's not very interesting but
something like that you might see how we
interpreted it like maybe that's a bit
ambiguous maybe you meant you know ^ 2x
so you can change your input based on
that you can kind of see your previous
attempts here and then we give you three
attempts and if you don't get it on the
third attempt it'll pop up the step by
step solution again that we've stole
from alpha another cool thing is let me
that's a perfect one to do that way okay
so our like we don't want people to
cheat but if you typed in something like
this instead of getting like a generic
hint you would get you know since this
is equivalent to the right answer just
not simplified it just asks you to
simplify the answer okay
and the link to their if you guys check
out the the website after you can get a
copy this notebook and you can check
things out on the links there so some
things we're doing in the future the
first one is more content geometry
trigonometry physics these are all in
the works I've got some kind of sample
things to show off for that so pretty
pictures with trig and geometry there's
like some systems of equations that
we're we're kind of the final stages of
about to release some physics stuff that
we're working on we have these nice like
known quantities tables we're kind of in
early talks with chemistry and physics
kind of generating and and generating
word problems is also another thing that
we're really interested in doing like
how do you generate a random phrase
right now we kind of use templated
things but yeah that's a that's a cool
problem that we're looking to solve in
addition to that the site is going to
have some visual and interactivity
improvements pretty soon further down
the line we're wanting to get some like
teacher administrative tools so we can
have better user history tracking like
I'd like you to be able to see every
single problem that you've ever done you
know maybe sending your answers to a
third party so we can kind of have
online tests for people and I love the
idea of like certifications or gaming or
leveling up you know systems like that
that are built in I know Khan Academy
does a lot of really cool stuff like
that better hint generation right now
it's partially pulled from the the step
by step but I we've kind of looked into
ways to use machine learning to maybe
tell where the user went wrong the
previous few talks were really cool
about all the machine learning stuff
that's going on in version 11 so I'm
hoping to dig in this under that and
then same with with problem selection so
kind of the dream is to present a user
with a problem and if they do really
well on it and they do it really fast
then we'll give them a harder problem
and then if they're having trouble with
it well maybe give them a the same level
or an easier problem yeah integration
with Wolfram Alpha a better integration
with that and maybe other Wolfram
products on their shelf the poem sheets
[Music]
let's see this is a pro feature but if
you are logged in it should be fine I am
yeah so this would be something maybe
you would print out for a test or or
something like that so we have this page
where we have the download as a PDF so
that the idea of like a interactive
problem sheet like that came up so we
kind of threw something together this is
just kind of bare-bones like like early
let's refresh that kind of like a proof
of concept that we did but it's kind of
cool
we actually since the code base for
alpha is old at this point we built out
a you or an API to kind of build this
this problem set
again it's not super neat but the idea
of it was cool and then we actually took
that API and Steven showed this for like
a second yesterday but this is a way to
kind of generate problems for you know
an app developer or even a teacher then
kind of get like a list of problems here
that's super small but I just take my
word for it
and this makes use of the permissions
key so this is just a cloud object those
built with the API and the particular
key for this is that I used was WTC 16
so if you guys again the links in the
notebook but if you guys go to this page
you should be able to check this out and
play around with it there's various like
export formats and the the simple
version just asks the question or just
list the question but that the full
version will give you the question the
answer the the different distractors
which I guess for is this prime or not
there aren't very many other distractors
where's the cooler one
[Music]
through it a way to zoom in I don't know
there we go so yeah here you can see
there's like an ID question answer the
various distractors that we generate for
that problem
[Music]
so yeah there's the link there I guess
in summary there's like a huge potential
for growth we're a pretty small team
hoping to grow right now I'm the only
full-time developer working on this
project that's typically been how it's
been since the beginning there's been
one person working on it but there's
other people kind of you know making
their own like like adding a new problem
type is easier than you would think it
would be so the the kind of short term
goal is everything that Wolfram Alpha
has step-by-step for we want to have
problem generation four so we do collect
user feedback so if you not on this page
but on either the homepage or any of the
problem pages you open this thing and
fill that out our feedback seems awesome
they'd be able to get those messages to
us so yeah please try it out and I think
I've got some time so if you guys have
any questions or comments